um so good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the first official south of
museum enact gallery meeting via audio
visual link via the platform of zoom due
to cobra 19 today on thursday the 2nd of
april welcome to all of our trustees
media even cured it and welcomed into
our our staff and crew from McCarthy
media and of course our Museum kill de
coche everybody very quickly I just want
bridge and Christine to maybe give a wee
bit of introduction because I know that
we haven't had a meeting with you all
together a breach your good afternoon
everybody my name's Britt hosted council
counselor counselor was 38 just 12 years
youngest I chair the council and
previously had quite a bit at the time
on these self and regional heritage to
me and yeah the members of that
committee busy during the day so that's
how I ended up being appointed so thank
you very much for having me on board
pewter and wrapkin Bri and welcome to
you Hannah um from communications ICC I
see you've just popped on here so cure
day I Christine oh well if you want to
do a quick introduction because I don't
believe everybody's meet you means these
all Christopher yes Christine means a
good afternoon my name is Christine
minzy's I'm a first-time counselor with
the District Council so very new to
these processes but enjoying it so far
into a background and education health
and welfare across the public service
for the last new to Yogi's but see
Marita
I'm just working part-time thanks
Christine you'll be right in your
element at this part at this time in yes
sort of that's great so I just want to
move to the agenda I'm hoping that you
can all see your agenda in front of you
but we do have an apology from Julie
help me out here from Jamie botting from
ICC who is our accountant in an apology
for lateness from Rebecca so if if
anyone's happy to move that we accept
those apologies I'll just get you to
raise your right hand something like
this
thank you Evelyn and I'll have that
seconded by Councillor Ludlow um all
those in favor raise your right hand
against do a cartwheel thank you moving
on to our interest register as you know
it's important to feed that information
through to Julie Thompson to have their
updated is standard
so I'll just allow that to pass through
and as it is in if there's any updates
there that you make sure that they come
through to myself for Julie to be added
to the interest register minutes of our
last meeting held on the 27th of
February if anyone is willing to move
that they are Thank You Darren
councillor Ludlow at that they are true
in correct - seconded by Tony can I can
I just hear them before you do yet it's
Christine means II see it there were
comments attributed to me in the minutes
but I think they were rather Christine
Thank You Christine Henderson not
Christine Menzies and Julie can you just
hand up that you've received it perfect
thank you there will be an opportunity I
just want to make sure that we've got to
move it in a seconder of the minutes
before we go into questions and
discussion I
the mover I think that was Darrin and
into second so happy to take discussion
around those minutes my own note please
madam chair item 10.1 the spelling for
very serious names else your name is if
CI a is CI a Thank You queen appreciate
that Julie's nodding her head so I think
she's got that now I take questions
first from Evelyn why is this honest I
met her tamari or tamari as a as
incorrect as well can I just type the
correction to Jolly that would be
perfect thank you thank you
lovely so no questions in regards to the
minutes no discussion around the minutes
I'll reread what I've supposed to have
said on behalf of Christine amazing
picture of necessary Tony Thank You
Christine Henderson I'd ask that you may
be seen it through sure Julie Thompson
so that she can make sure that those
minutes are correct so with those money
I'll make your life a bit easier just
call me Chris okay in a Christine press
in Christine sounds good to me
thank you and so I've no discussion no
questions I'll put that motion all in
favor raise your right whatever you've
got against carries Thank You team this
is this is good
moving to the financial report you will
see from Jamie bottom that there is one
payment for authorization to be approved
and there is true payable to McCarthy
media and communications for media
release work done on the 3rd and the 9th
of March if there's no questions I'd be
happy to move that motion that we get
that paid in it payment be authorized
and approved can I have a seconder for
that please I'll take it
thank you Chris any discussion around
that payment
beautiful all those in favor raise your
right hand against carries ah beautiful
thank you you can eat another week thank
you operational report I'm going to mute
myself thank goodness and hand you over
firstly to David dud field and nin to
cumberly's Stephens to go over this
report Thank You toon gotta koto so I'll
just read the curatorial section of
report so the fill out for the interim
museum and gallery space has now been
completed our compliance for the space
has not yet been issued due to the
pandemic so it was completed I believe
on the Monday before the lockdown so
just waiting for the restrictions to
ease up a little bit so we can get in
there and get that code compliance in
the meantime we're monitoring the
environment the temperature and relative
humidity in there using the building
management system and independent data
loggers um-hmm as far as we can tell it
seems to be going pretty well at this
stage it looks like it's hitting the
right targets so that's some positive of
the positive news as far as taught the
teams up to the curatorial team we're
all obviously as everyone's working from
home at the moment creating content
developing programs for me in each new
space and we are also working with
external designers and comms such as
McCarthy media for potential openings
which may later than plane so we're
still aiming as soon as we're able to
move into Calvin Street start installing
the exhibition as soon as we're able to
so it will take about two months roughly
to install the first exhibition was the
I think Daffy
I can't mute em from Mike so I'm gonna
make a phone call I yes I am Tony I've
just I've just joined in ah been a bit
of a rigmarole oh that's okay thank you
and welcome and we're all on we just up
to the operational report from David
Doug field can I ask you pilot mute your
end yeah I think I hear but I'll just
take it no worries thank you cool so
yeah so the the pending make will affect
out our opening because we don't want to
get large groups of people in together
obvious reasons so we just sort of play
that by ear it's a little bit of playing
everything by ear as Eve runners so but
we're still with the team's positive
everyone's doing good work and we're
still still getting quite a few
providing services such as research and
genealogies everyone seems to be at home
and curious to find out about their
ancestors which is quite cool and maybe
do you Kimberly speaking to the report
so in February work continued on the can
logging and packing and addressing
compliance concerns and then obviously
like March 19 response so very proud of
the collections T and they all pivoted
very quickly and and so we've got two of
our team building travel frames and
packing components and their garages
we've got people entering data from
projects that were put into spreadsheets
before and we're doing some really
valuable important work on improving the
accuracy of the database particularly in
relation to people in places which is
very exciting because it all flows on to
fixing some of our compliance issues and
just making our collections more
accessible and enabling us to do future
engagement projects with the communities
so particularly around Tonga body it's
very exciting
in the building the tuatara and it's
being monitored and cared for on a daily
basis by myself in one of the collection
technicians with lindsay going in he's
doing a feed today so he'll just pop in
and make sure that they're healthy and
well and his stomachs are full and the
only other thing David didn't talk about
was we're doing some social media work
around providing activities for bono at
a time when he's probably a lot of
stress with keeping children occupied so
it's been quite nice to be able to
contribute to the community in that way
sorry
it was silly wasn't it
Thank You Kimberly thank you David I
absolutely total caught your corridor
around the staff and how quickly they
were to respond and have it in
continuing is business as usual as much
as we can hear business is usually at
this time Hina
you've got the puppy um distractions no
sorry any questions are moved to
councillor Ludlow thank you just a quick
question Kimberly with that stuff for
allowing Ferno to interact is that going
to be delivered online so there will be
a future project so obviously we have a
lot of collections would probably look
to doing engagement with the a way from
which things are provenance once we get
that information in communities so we
hold a lot of things that came in at a
time when source communities weren't
really consulted so it's about kind of
building up our knowledge base so we can
get to a point where we can go out and
do that the reason that I ask is having
had a look at a couple of museum sites
off sure I noticed the using the
lockdown period is a great chance to
gather information from people so if
there was in
the opportunity that you are able to
open that up to get information and just
let us know so we can read it out thank
you Thank You Darren is the any other
questions on that particular report
Evelyn just directed to David and you
came to me for something you're going to
do an article on tuatara for a social
media thing I haven't seen it as they're
a work in progress
Oh actually what's happening right as
you speak Lindsey is feeding at ortero
now and he is I think he's taking a
photograph or a wee video of them so I'm
yet to see what it looks like but yeah
you might see something relatively soon
so fantastic I just I was curious
because you know I monitor your page
it's much appreciated thank you actually
ventolin thank you David I just want to
clarify is that a social media article
going out all media it's a social media
post just to let people know what's
happening with the tuatara just to make
sure that everyone knows that they've
been cared for in secure drinking great
idea nitrogen can I make a plea to David
to actually let myself in timers know
it's Rob because I'm afraid not everyone
is on social media yeah absolutely
the only reason I run zoom is because
I've got a son who's a an IT M
programmer otherwise I'd be stumped so
self and Times article good news and
we'll be lovely about the tuatara it's a
good point Christine yeah and well done
David good report thanks David that even
good news good news I'm sure he thinks
I'm cheating yeah kasi maybe I'm
watching you no just kidding okay on in
upwards we go or general business sorry
let me go back there Opera operational
report I'm happy to move that we receive
that report
Christine is happy to see connect so all
those in favor raise your right hand
against carriage beautiful people
general business and so as we know we
have a retailed report from mr. Eagles I
will allow Rodgers some time to speak to
this before we open the discussion
move the motion and resolve the report
Roger can you hear me now yes that that
earlier motion does not now need to be
put because after the the last meeting
somehow there Tim Walker report was
released to to the media and even even
for first sort of a summary of it but
then later much more content was
actually published so I think the
consideration of that motion does not
now need to occur because it's now out
in the in the public domain
thanks Roger my understanding and I may
be incorrect is that we still need to
resolve is a group to release the report
and then give it it seemed it to the
public eye at this stage I only think
it's even got the report due to someone
giving it to him the public have not yet
received or seeing the report yeah I'm
quite happy to renew the motion that the
our board should agree to the release of
the report now and in that way it's
formalized totally agree with must
Eagles long paper do second it thank you
Roger ncq Gary so with that in mind
there is a motion to that the board
resolved to release a copy of the Tim
Walker report to the public can I just
ask if there's anyone who would like to
discuss anything around that if you want
to raise your hand so I can Green did
you have your hand up I did Tony but I
was actually pre-empting the vote okay
okay sorry I'll go to evil and then I
believe that she had her hand up are you
wanting a Christian yet um if we are
formally going to agree to release the
document the report which which somebody
else is already given to the south and
times is this a an opportunity for the
board to have a bigger discussion with
the media about the feelings about what
is in the report the report itself see
certain things but we as a
bored have not had an opportunity to
speak to the report in any open way as
this where we get to have that say um
I'm happy to open a discussion around
the report I would encourage people to
send me their views in opinions around
the report either via video conference
or now I'm just wondering how everybody
else feels about that I'd love to ask
Sara and Phil actually from a
communications perspective how they feel
about having a discussion around the
report with the media present today and
I would ask Sara infill to give us some
advice around there in henna as possible
from ICC
um thanks for that I think there with
once the reporters released publicly
being I guess the text the shackles off
but I guess it's still you know still in
terms of the way the board operates in
terms of collective responsibility do
you speak individually or as a board
through the chair so I think those same
rules apply so I guess you need to just
have we think about that I think people
are free to speak about the contents in
the report thanks Sarah I think you Phil
I keep looking at the name Hannah look
to a certain extent and wait way to
throw me in here Tony no look I would
agree wouldn't Phil end and Sarah cuz
I'm sure Sierra always agrees with Phil
no I totally understand that the board
has always had a strong desire and fit
to seek the community's views to hear
from the community in relation to the
report I would encourage you to continue
seeking guidance and support from Sarah
in Phil and the sense that any proposal
of this nature will risk will require
about shepherding and support from from
you either trust forward and making sure
that you can answer those public
questions and you've thought about all
of those things that may have been
particularly given that with everybody
and lock down that present people have a
little bit more time perhaps to share
their views on platforms like social
media and there and that can be quite a
big job in itself you know in my
apologies for throwing you and me but
you've done really well I'm just got
away young man having just a slight
meltdown at this one
when I say slight I mean quite a big one
so I'm thinking I it would be happy to
move that motion if the mover and
seconder would consider maybe amending
it to the fact that we do have an
opportunity to speak to the media
through the chair of the board as we
always have in relation to the report if
necessary if necessary guided by as the
Mike McCarthy media effect would satisfy
you
evylyn yes it would Tony thank you no
worry so if these if the movement in
Sikandar are happy with it could you
both raise your hand
happy with it great so we'll I mean that
motion that the board resolves to
release a copy of the term Walker report
to the public that the Smeg trust board
if required will speak to media through
the chair around the context of the
report with the support of McCarthy
media something like that we're assuming
Tony that there's not a unanimous
response to the term Walker report from
the Smeg board that we perhaps have
individual thoughts about it which we
need to make you aware of beautiful and
there will be a time where we get to
speak to the report through the workshop
I'm just not sure what date concern so
we take him so in favor please raise
your right hand
um Tony may I just ask would it be wise
to hold off until after the workshop or
was the workshop sort of in the never
never now because of the covert nineteen
block down or the council's hoping to do
something online
so I'm referring to our workshop is a
trust board are they all right okay I'm
to talk about the term Walker report
itself right I just want to reiterate
that we have had a huge amount of
opportunity to discuss the term Walker
report as a transport on many many
different occasions so I'm wanting to
make sure that that we all have an
opportunity now that we have some new
trustees on board so I can in unhappy to
organize a workshop for this trust board
to have accorded or what about the
context of the report and you know I'm
sure that the ICC at SDC in the or
elected members can take the exeed back
back to the air councils well it may
help the new members to look at the
report and depth and express any
misgivings weyni points that they accept
and support but I'm sorry when I talked
about a workshop I was thinking about
the combined council workshop and
whether it be wise to me before that or
a way to an outcome from that meeting so
we've had our workshop the City Council
I'm I'm wondering if SDC in Gore head
head one my understanding was that each
council had resolved to put the
governance back through the Invercargill
City Council and the activity of the
museum to the city so that is my
understanding across the board from all
councils so there would not be a joint
council workshop okay you have to ask
Tony is that do you mean that we the
Smeg would will be disestablished and my
understanding is that the Smeg boards
would be re now there's a word for it
repurposed environmental to do what
at this stage I'm not sure it is it
seems that it would be to govern the
collection not the activity of the
museum that's a big step
I guess that's been resolved by all
councils I understand south and district
or end of the Congo and was that to do
with the supposed ownership of the
museum in the land that it sits on as
such what it's connected to a career
that has the decision around that has
been made by amber caudill City Council
which is very government because I just
wondered initially that whole entity the
Southland museum would have been prayed
for by the rate payers of Invercargill
Southland and Gore and I just wonder if
that's a pre-emptive decision because
the public haven't been consulted and
they don't know what the ramifications
will be and I just wonder if this is
another thing that should be seen to ask
for public consultation at appropriate
time either to ratify the decision by
the by the council or to choose some
other way of governance which makes it
possible for the community to have more
say in the running of the museum because
it's a big step and I think have gone
through by default without public
consultation in smeg Board reference so
I I can't answer that cuz if you've the
documents that we've obtained as a trust
board indicates that the vacarros City
Council the board District Council in
the Southland District Council have all
resolved across the board to make the
same decision that as a decision made by
the regional councils and that is a
southern region decision the MV coggle
City Council will put out their
recommendation to the public about the
governance structure in the annual plan
to be consulted on that was always going
to happen the timeframe around there
juda koba's I am yet to determine what
that would be but we were always going
to consult on the governance change in
Vacaville I can't speak for Gore and I
can't speak for South and District
Council but we have rips from the areas
and I welcome them to to discuss that
you have some that up pretty well
the Brixton there's two things Krista's
the bricks and mortar and then there's
the governance structure behind that so
our chair is quite right that once it
was established that the bricks and
mortar so to speak was owned by the
Imperial City that changed the whole
concept and then as the chair said that
will go out for community consultation
once we get all their ducks in a row
merely a stretcher q Gary and brick from
Gore have you anything to contribute to
their no listen Tony you and Gary if
some of them go so thank you anyone has
any questions are we on there if you
just want to pop I'll thank you Roger
yes I'm me and I'm chairman this issue
about ownership of the museum and the
land and so on there's not one which our
board has ever
properly considered that all we breeders
in the newspaper the CEO of the amber
Carol City Council I said that she
satisfied that the macaco City Council
owns the museum and I we may form our
own view about that in the end it may
not be critical about anything but we've
not seen I had put in front of us any
legal opinions at all which establish
ownership or tend to establish ownership
and it really contrary to the
understanding of the museum and Trust
Board so although it's a collateral
issue I think that we as a board should
insist upon seeing any legal opinions
which have been composed on those Indian
reserve the right to maybe get our own
opinion of course it may be that we we
think the legal opinions are look sound
and reasonable and we and we could
accept them
without that information and we're not
doing our role as a board and trying to
protect what could be our own se Thank
You Roger and I absolutely agree and
like I had said previously this is an
opportunity where our board can have
that discussion and put a motion but
lots of conversation and debate around
it or discussion never really leads to
anyone putting to the floor a motion to
move on that so I encourage you at this
time as trustees as if if you do feel
strongly about those issues this would
be an opportunity in our committee
meeting to move a motion to put that to
Council until such time you know we will
continue to go around in conversation so
I'm open to that and encourage the
debate in discussion well I would be
quite happy to move now madam chairman
that this board formally request of the
under chemical City Council copies of
all documentation including legal
opinions which have been provided to
Council leading towards views about
ownership of the museum and the land on
which asserts Thank You Roger
I appreciate that with that motion on
the floor is the anyone do that would
see connect motion yes I'll second that
Tony thank you Chris
any further discussion and questions
around net motion Evelyn I'm just point
of clarification I don't think any
debate owns the land underneath the
building because it's legally part of
Queens Park before it must be owned by
default now I'm not a lawyer
Roger is but I would think that it would
be the case I think the ownership of the
building as well we should be
questioning is that correct I think so
right because I understand it to be City
Council reserved land so you're you are
correct it is just the building with
which we're concerned
daran that you have a question
not really a question more a statement
it's it's under what do you hope to
achieve you don't own the lien because
that's City Council Reserve you own a
building which isn't up to code which
you responsible shown that the City
Council is actually I'm just I'm happy
to cite the papers then it's the
responsibility for the upgrade the South
Museum of that gallery Trust Board in
its duration at the moment will simply
ask him to save you so much thing in the
cargo City Council has reached its
Bureau this is a very complete country
to the Museum Trust Board showing us an
asset which knowledge is everything on
these situations and in the end actually
owning a museum may be a liability the
museum built likely a liability rather
than an asset I understand there but I
still think we need to know and respect
to the bowling I agree because everybody
may be to stick it and we get some
instructions
Evelyn's a sign queen I agree because if
that's a misconception on our part
regarding the ownership of the building
it's been a misconception that's been
held by boards Steve stress boards of
the museum since 1960 which is quite a
long period of time to be and acting
under a misconception so it would be
good to view any documents and surely
that wouldn't mean that we're actually
we actually would own legal fees or have
to pay legal fees that's met reviewing
the documents that CEOs has in her
office stating this new development
Thank You queen so since I raised the
point Tony I'm quite comfortable with
everybody citing the papers I just on a
legal opinion yeah Thank You Darren and
Gary I think you had a question question
is along the same lines of counsel
Dudley but I'm going to support the
motion for the point of clarification to
get everything get all the cards on the
table I can see or I can hear this
confusion out there so let's sort of l
thank you motion get might put the
motion not yet okay so I move into mover
in a seconder for the motion and Julie
I'm just wondering if you could just
speak their motion again because I can
see Darren as signalling for that to be
read out
I've lost sound you haven't we're just
waiting for Julie I can hear us can you
hear us Julie can you unmute yourself
the others
thank you ma'am IV now cuz I fries I
couldn't couldn't get em get on okay
well I got some of what mister what
Roger see it and I do get most of it
back from the tape as well when I go
through the recording um Roger and I can
take us through that once more formally
request
yep that this board formal request of
the invocation City Council opinions and
respect to one of the museum building
yep a mostest yeah okay all those in
favor raise your right hand against
brilliant carries thank you thank you
everybody I'm now gonna move that we
move into public excluded unless these
in the